coucou madame la Présidente
permettez-moi de commencer mon
intervention en ayant une pensée pour
les victimes de l'attentat terroriste de
Nice puisque c'est aujourd'hui que le
verdict sera rendu public ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
vous avez présenté en juillet en conseil
des ministres un décret pour renforcer
les missions du corps donateur national
du renseignement et de lutte contre le
terrorisme vous avez alors insisté sur
le relais essentiel que ce dernier
assurait pour justement assurer la
sécurité intérieure ainsi que la
protection de nos concitoyens et de
notre pays vous aviez alors
souhaité améliorer la prise en compte
des enjeux à la fois du renseignement et
du terrorisme pourtant 15 jours après
vous avez nommé celui qui assuré cette
mission si importante préférée de police
de Paris il en résulte que depuis plus
de 5 mois le pays n'a plus de
coordonnateurs nationales du
renseignement et de lutte contre le
terrorisme c'est paradoxal par rapport à
vos propres déclarations madame la
Première ministre c'est aussi très grave
car cette vacance est très dangereuse
madame la Première ministre quant
allez-vous enfin nommer le remplaçant de
Monsieur nounes pour protéger
efficacement la nation car même si le
risque zéro n'existe pas vous avez une
obligation de moyens pour réduire au
maximum le risque terroriste d'autant
que votre Ministre de l'Intérieur vient
de déclarer pas plus tard qu'hier que la
menace terroriste était à nouveau
extrêmement élevé je vous remercie